欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课我们来讲一下 寻盘质量低怎么样去提升
前面我们已经讲了关于如何去判断寻盘质量的问题
那么我们已经知道怎么样去判断了
知道了我们店铺内确实是寻盘质量太差
那么这种情况我们怎么样去提升呢
首先我们来先了解一下寻盘质量低的原因是什么导致的
第一个可能是你的店铺新等级太低
如果你是零星跟一星其实差别是很大的
两星跟三星四星五星它的差别也是很大的
因为现在平台是讲究的是买家跟卖家匹配
如果你是零星说比你的实力太差
平台不可能给你分配那么多的高质量的买家
因为他担心你承接不了这些买家的需求
导致这些客户的流失
那么这些客户的流失也就是对平台的体验不好
就会导致客户离开这个平台
那么这个是平台的损失
所以他会把那些有更高能力的商家
推荐给这些高质量的买家
这样让他们能够精准的比配
这样才能够实现交易
所以说星级是其中的一个维度
我们一定要重视星级
星级只是决定它的分配的权益跟它的一个占比
并不代表说你零星跟一星没有优质客户
一样是有优质客户的
只不过是说它的数量会少一点
第二个就是
店铺的标签非常混乱
因为我们现在的系统推荐的流量
都是根据店铺的标签
产品的标签
池的标签
以及一些国家的标签
来进行推荐
产品体配买家的
所以说我们前期的店铺标签
如果很多都是来自非目标国家的法科
那么是不是你的店铺就会积累了大量的
不精准的标签
这个时候
如果你某一款产品非常好
但是它的一个标签非常乱
那么是不是系统也会跟着
给你推荐更加偏的流量
那么这些质量就更差
也会导致你整个店铺的
巡盘质量非常的差
巡盘虽然多
但是它都是来自非目标国家的
所以说它的质量其实就是很差的
第三个就是我们在选款的时候
没有去注重目标国家的选品
很多时候我们只是
想去看哪些产品卖的好
我们就去选款
但是你忽略了
目标国家偏好的类型
你跟你这个店铺里面
要发的产品类型是不一致的
所以你要根据你的主营市场去发产品
去选产品
这样才能够获得更多的主营市场目标国家的巡盘
你的巡盘的质量才会更好
第四个就是如果你的产品发布都是用低
NOQ和低起定量来作为引流起点的话
那么很有可能也会导致你整个店铺的巡盘的质量都是非常低的
因为如果你的店铺是做高
NOQ和价格比较高的
如果你用低价引流客户看到的都是被你的这个起定量跟价格吸引的
那么他进来的时候第一反应就是你的产品这些起定量跟价格他能接受的
如果客户进来跟业务聊天的时候发现你的起定量跟价格跟你的产品完全不搭边
或者是你的业务聊的起定量跟价格都是非常高的
那么就跟进来的这些客户的需求不匹配
就容易导致他没有办法成交
每天都聊得很火热
每天都很忙
业务每天都很忙
但是呢
他就是没有业绩
因为聊的都是一些低质量的客户
他很活跃也跟你聊
但是呢最终说到成交或者是说订单金额啊
起定量啊这些都没有办法实现
所以说就导致你整个店铺
巡盘非常多
聊的也很多
但是订单非常的少
交易额非常少
所以这个问题大家一定一定要重视
这四个方面是导致我们店铺巡盘质量非常差
差的原因
那么我们知道的原因了
那么我们怎么样去分析和提升呢
接下来我们来详细讲解一下如何去提升我们店铺的
巡盘质量
第一个我们先从店铺重极去看
看什么呢
我们店铺的定位你一定要明确
你是做定制赛道
还是做RTS赛道
这两个赛道是不一样的
他所对应的人群也是不一样的
所以我们在做这些店铺定位的时候
以及后续的运营的过程中都是围绕着我们店铺定位来进行开展各项运营工作的
那关于这个店铺定位如果你不是很清晰那么可以回去听我们之前讲的店铺定位的内容
这个一定要明确一定是围绕着这个去做店铺的
第二个就是你的价格跟起定量一定要是跟你实际能够承接订单的真实价格跟起定量是接近的
不能太低太低的话也可能导致你寻盘多了
但是你订单成交不了
所以说这个一定要根据自身的实际情况去做
也不能太高太高的话
还有可能就是连寻盘都没有
所以说这个非常的关键
不要忽视这个因素
第三个就是我们上面讲的
你的目标国家跟人群是否准确
比如说你的星级零星可能比配的买家可能质量会相对低一点点
同时呢他的优质买家可能占比比较少
但是你达到了三星到五星
那么平台给你分配的总的优质买家占比就会上升一点
但是呢并不代表你都能够获得优质买家
这里面的话你要去锁定你目标国家的优质买家
才是你真正的目标人群
有些买家可能是三星L3L4L2
但是呢这些都是你非目标国家的高质量的人群
也很难让你成交
所以说这个也是我们重点关注的一个部分
第四个就是我们前面也讲了你的款式必须符合你的主营市场
比如说你做的是欧美市场
你就不要去发那些东南亚
非洲沙特等等这些中东等这些国家的一些款式
你一定是要根据你的主营目标市场去选款
和去选属性去发布产品的
第五个就是我们产品是不是经常会有很多标签混乱
所以说我们前期要在单品上面一定要在前期沉淀足量的精准数据
也就是你至少要能够确保你的
访客的国家产品访客的国家是精准的
首先第一个就是先锁定目标国家
这样的话你的产品只要出现了爆品
同时它流量非常大的时候
那么你获得系统推荐的流量就会更加的精准
那么你的数据沉淀的越多
那么你的整个店铺的总的精准目标的访客量就会越来越大
那么你的店铺层级的那个精准标签就越多
那么你后期获得的精准流量
平台分配的流量就会更精准
那么这个就是我们店铺层级的
第二个我们来看一下产品层级的
比如说我们的产品有一个或者是一两个
质量流量非常好
但是这些质量流量都来自于我们非目标国家的一些寻盘
或者是一些流量
这种产品的话会直接拉低了我们店铺的标签精准度
以及拉偏了我们产品的标签精准度
这样的话后期无论你这个产品的流量再大
你也是没有办法把寻盘转化成订单的
因为这些国家都不是你能做的国家
也无法成交的国家
这种情况我们就把这些产品
直接下架两到三天把他的标签打断
再重新上架
第二个就是我们要去把产品详情页优化一下
把它优化成我们目标国家市场偏好的内容
看看能不能吸引到一些目标国家的循环
第三个如果你的款式都是非目标国家偏好的
那么你可以考虑在这个链接上面去换一个我们目标国家市场的款式
那么换了这个款式之后你会发现原来它的自然流量会直接下降
所以你要做好自然流量下降的准备
但是它下降对你来说其实也未必不是一件好事
因为你下降的流量是那些非目标国家的流量
也可以有效的提升你的产品的精准度和店铺的精准度
第二个就是持通车的流量
也就是你在推广直通车的时候很有可能你都没有锁定目标国家
所以说导致很多都是非目标国家的点击
那么点的越多积累的数据越多
那么你的这个产品
它的标签就越差
标签差后面系统给你推荐的流量就越质量越低
所以说你一定要注意
持通车是花钱的一定要把你的钱花在你的目标国家上
一定要优先考虑目标国家花钱
这样你的国家至少精准了
那么后续你整个国家的标签就精准了
精准了之后我们再去调整人群
那么我们的整个店铺跟产品的标签就会更加的精准
第三个就是我们在信保保定的时候
一定要想办法去用我们目标市场的国家的订单
订单来绑定我们的报款产品以及我们本身转化很好的产品
就用目标国家的订单去绑定
第四个就是
单品低质量寻盘
我们可以考虑就是把它移动到垃圾寻盘
类似这种质量流量非常多
寻盘也非常多
但是都是来自一些我们承接不了的国家
那么这种寻盘我们可以把它移动到垃圾寻盘里面
移到垃圾寻盘呢
有利于我们去把这个产品的标签
扭转成为我们目标市场的标签
因为你把它移到垃圾寻盘
就是在告诉系统
我不是偏好这一类国家
我不需要这一类寻盘
那么在后期系统推荐的时候
就会减少这些国家的推荐
就能够有效的降低我们整个店铺标签的低质量
那么我们常见的案例是哪些呢
很多人的寻盘每个月非常多
但是成交的订单都是非常少的
比如说它一个月1000条寻盘
一个月500条寻盘
但是呢成交的订单可能一两个
或者是更少
那么这种都是因为它的一个标签不精准
以及寻盘质量太差导致的
那么我们的优化方法
就参考我们上面的这些方法
去优化就可以了
那么我们的每一个方法
都是对应我们后台的每一项操作
如果你不是特别清楚的时候
那么你对照的这个思路
去后台直接去操作
那么你操作多几次
你就有印象
你就能够理解
为什么我可以这样操作
这样操作
对你有什么好处
只有这样
你才能够
构建一整套更加完善的思考方向和时操的方法
第三个就是直通车层级
在这个层级里面
如果你不注意去精准推广
那么也会导致我们的产品标签的混乱
店铺标签的混乱
你看这条线反过来
全部沉淀在这些数据里面
所以直通车推广一定要非常的重视
因为这是花钱买流量的
所以一定要想办法去买更多优质的目标国家的流量
我们来看一下具体的提升方法
第一个高点击词
高点击的国家精准性是否精准
也就是我们要去看我们的词报告里面的点击的词是不是准确的
以及我们这个计划的点击的国家是不是我们目标国家
是不是我们这类产品更偏好的国家
第二个就是我们要去看一下高点击的人群标签
人群标签
这些高点击的人群标签
目标国家
比如说已经对了
那么这些高点击的人群标签
是否有一项商机
LE+占比大不大
如果有一项商机
LE+占比也大了
那么说明我们这个标签是非常精准的
如果LE+占比低
同时国家也不精准
那么我们就要想办法去把这个人群标签降低意价
然后提升其他标签的意价
来测试其他标签的精准性
不然的话
我们如果没有去注意这个高点击的人群标签
那么就会消耗我们非常多的预算
然后来的人群又不精准
导致我们没有办法获得有效的询盘
第三个就是你要去判断
你推广的产品的款式是否符合市场偏好
以及目标国家的偏好
因为选品在直冬车推广
就决定了我们整个直冬车的效果
产品是源头
所以一定要选对
第四个就是效果太差的计划
然后果断暂停
特别是那种超过一个月的计划
如果效果都非常差
怎么样差呢
比如说1点击词都不是我们目标的精准词
第二个就是反客国家都不准确
第三个就是那些标签
都是新买家标签啊
还有那些D NOQ那些标签
如我这些标签的点击量非常多
而且其他的标签的L1+占比低
亦象商机少
那么这种标签都是可以判断出我们整个计划效果是非常差的
那么这种时候我们一定要想办法去直接把这个计划暂停
重新去创建一个计划比你在原计划去不断的调整
效果会更好
因为这个计划推广的时间太长了
那么系统已经知道它的这个方向是怎么样去推广了
那么这个方向本来就是错的
标签本来就是乱的
差的
那么这种情况暂停是最好的
那么我们重新创建一个计划
就按照最标准的方式
去锁定目标国家跟人群
然后选择更好的产品去推广
那么这时候效果才会更好
我们来看一个案例
比如说你们的店铺里面有一些寻盘非常好的报品
但是呢这些报品都是零转化
那么这种你要怎么去提升呢
首先第一个你要去看一下
你这些报品里面的这些寻盘的国家
来不来自你目标的市场
如果都是非目标国家市场的寻盘
那么这个寻盘没有成交是很正常的
如果国家不对
那么先扭转国家
第二个就是你在推广这个报品的时候
来的国家是精准的
但是他总是低质量
也就是国家对了
但是他的层级可能是L0客户
L1+客户
但是这些质量比较差
这种情况你怎么去解决呢
去找到店铺里面的定向标签
你去看看这个计划里面的定向标签
哪个定向标签里面的数据是大的
比如说高点击的
一项张机也多的
但是L1+占比少的
这种情况你就可以考虑把这个计划里面的定向标签调整为101意价
然后把另一个标签比如B标签C标签这种标签提升意价
可能比如说你平时意价到120
那么你直接提升到150意价
甚至更高
这样的话我们就能够有效的把点击量积累在B标签和C标签上面减少A标签的一个点击量
那么我们就可以测试看看BC它里面的L1占比多不多
如果L1+占比多同时还能带来询盘
那么你这些询盘一定是L1+以上的质量的买家
所以这个思路非常的重要
这里就是相当于讲了直动车如何去优化
在你推广报品的时候如何优化你这个报品计划
那么以上就是关于寻盘质量怎么提升的三个维度去提升
通过电路层级还有产品层级
直动车层级一步步的去提升
那么它们之间都是有关联性的
我们在去调整的时候
很有可能我们在这里调整了之后
后面的这部分可能就不需要调整了
因为前面的这部分调整了
那么它是直接影响到后面的这些的
所以我们在调整的时候
并不是说这些内容全部都要去调整
我们这里面讲的都是一些详细的分析思路
那么你只需要
针对着里面的某一条某一条去
针对性的去看
就针对性的去调整就可以了
这是一个比较综合的应用
那么我们来看一下后台的时潮演示
比如说我们这里看到的就是店铺重新定位
这个就不讲了
我们直接看我们那个捷克的内容
第二个就是价格起定量
我们上一节课已经讲过了如何去看
第三个就是明确国家跟人群
这些也讲了那款式
我们可以在这里看一下
我们可以在这里面
我们首先选择我们可以先选择国家
进入到比如说你的市场是美国
美国了之后
你看这里有个热品分析
热品分析之后
你都要在这里选择你的内幕
在这里选择你的内幕
这个国家已经定了
那么你就来看这里
访问偏好的产品是哪些
你按照这里去选品
把你的店铺里面的相似的款式
或者风格的产品
比较好数据的拿去推广
这里选是比较和好的
同时呢
你这里参考的款式
你一定要去结合你的一个
优品里面数据去综合判断
不能单独觉得你店铺里面
有这样的款式
你就直接去推广
有这样的款式还不行
你要结合你那个款式
是不是当前的店铺里面的优品
或者是是不是有一定的数据沉淀
这样去选品综合的分析
才能够选得到更好的产品
那么这个就是询盘的
我们通常选什么样
怎么样去选呢
就是把产品访客编号的
跟产品寻盘排名的一起
结合去选
它们之间有相同的产品
就是优先选择
比如说这款产品
在产品编号里面也有
然后在访问编号里面也有
我们就优先选择这类的产品
就是同时在两个板块出现
第二种情况呢
可以直接从类目去选
比如说我不知道我的目标国家是哪些
那我们先去看我们的品类
看品类的时候
我们去看看
你看这里有个产品榜单
我们一般来说看效果
效果的话就是寻盘
tm 订单的产品
那么我们也可以在这里看
看这些哪些跟我们相似的
我们去参考这些去选择
很有可能这里出现的
跟你的整个店铺的都没有一样的
那么你就不需要参考它这里
没有说一定要跟它相同
因为这里可能就是那些目标国家
跟你的都不一样
所以说这里只是作为参考
接下来的话我们还可以在一个买家参谋
这里是不是会有一个订单跟寻盘
tm 我们去看这三个板块
或者是说你看一二三四四个板块的交集
也就是买家全占偏好的所有的这些产品的一些交集
你去选出来就可以了
当然你要选的时候
你这个本店的这是你店铺的
我建议看的是行业的
因为行业的话我们可以选择它的一个
呃
类目
我们把具体的类目选出来的时候
你就把这几个交集的选出来就可以了
把这些选出来
你的
自动车推广啊
或者是说你在发品选品的时候
就会比较清晰的知道
你当前的选择的产品是否准确
是否符合你目标市场的需求
第二个就是我们所说的
呃
单一产品突破
比如说你看产品分析
我们先点开产品分析
你去看产品的时候
比如说我们按月看
某个产品效果非常非常好
比如说
比如说这个效果非常好
但是你一定要去看
他的一个访客
是这一边是不是你目标国家的
比如说
这个产品效果非常好
群盘非常多
每个月给你整个店铺占比
百分之二十左右的群盘
但是呢
这些访客的国家都是一些
非目标国家的
比如说你都是做美国
加拿大
英国
法国
这些国家的
但是来的流量都是印度
韩国
墨西哥等等
一系列都是
东南亚
非洲啊
这些国家的
说明你这个
产品
积累的数据
虽然好
但是都不是你目标市场的
那么它这个产品的价值就很低
因为它已经偏离了你的目标市场
那么后期系统给你推荐的这个产品的话
也会导致它
悬盘质量不精准
很难成交
所以说这种产品我们前期一定要先沉淀
精准的数据
不然的话我们很难去突破
第二个就是产品自然流量
比如说这个产品自然流量非常非常的好
但是这些都不是我们想要的
这种情况怎么办呢
你又没有推广
你这里都没有推广
都没有推广
那么你这个产品可以直接下降
也就是说下降
两天再上升
这样的话就能够阻止系统给你推荐
因为你这里的流量来源可能很可能就是你看其他的流量跟
一些导购会场这些流量
如果你暂停了
是不是就能够阻断它
建议推荐
那么是不是这个效果
下一次你上架的时候
这里的流量减少了
减少了无效的流量
其他剩下的都是比较有效的流量
第二个就是你的价格起定量等等
都可以进行一个优化
首先
这个好的产品只要你去优化
那么它效果可能就变差
差的是那部分
非目标的流量减少而已
这样的话
其实对于你整个店铺的总流量来说
还是更加有利于你去优化成为更加精准的流量的
那么这个就是我们说的单品的
第二个就是
直动车的
我们这里就会展开了
因为我们直动车板块里面有讲的非常非常的详细
精准的绑定
信保订单
应该大家都能够清楚了
直动车的这种我们就不讲了
这种跟我们前面讲的这几个是有一定的从而性的
你看市场的判断的偏好
高点击的人群标签
我们去讲一下这个高点击的人群标签
找到你想要优化的那个计划
比如说和直动车
我们看一下商品成长里面优报品计划
我们随便打开一个计划
我这里是举例子并不是实际的
比如说我们看到数据分析里面去看
我们一般来说同时打开这两个把详情也打开
进去看数据分析
定向报告里面
比如说我们刚才讲的这个是高点击的人群标签分析
比如说我们来看一下所有标签所有
我们选按30天选数据大一点明显一点
我们来看这里来排序一下
比如说我们的奥义价买家像类似
比如说奥义价买家44个点击
他什么都没有
你看商机都没有
如果我们不优化这个标签
那么我们就可以先去优化我们的这里面的国家
因为很有可能你L1这里点击多
但是他没有给你发行吗
很有可能是你的这个国家本身不对
我们可能是保留L1家买家的溢价
我们去优化这个国家
把国家调整精准
那么我们这个L1的国家精准了
那么他这里的数据可能就会改变
比如说平台脑客
这些标签点击非常高
我这里举个例子
不一定是这个数据
比如说他的这个标签非常高是吧
点击量非常高是吧
他意向商机少
然后一家占比也低
这种情况呢
我们就按照我刚才讲的那个思路就是把这个标签降低
一家
然后比如说这些标签
效果很好
那么我这些标签就提升一家去测试
那么最后面这些标签的点击量增长起来了
这里也有数据了
那么就表明我的这些标签
对于我整个计划的产品推广来说是非常有效的
这种就说明没效
所以说我们是通过地价来调整来进行测试
找到更高转化的标签
按照这个思路去找就可以了
我这里的基本都是一些思路跟方法
如果你去参考的时候
一定要根据我的思路跟方法去找到对应的指标
去调整跟优化
因为你的数据跟我的数据是不一样的
而且这里没有一个很明显的例子
就没有办法给你一个非常准确的一个数据去判断
比如说你说点击量要多少才能调整
基本上在10个以上
我们就可以考虑去优化
特别是超过20个的
更加要重视去优化
不要等待
比如说这里前面这三个
超过20的
那么我们就不要去等待
一定要去持续的优化
这样才能够更快的见到结果
那么这个就是我们说的一个
人群标签的优化
款式刚才我们已经讲了在前面这些板块一样
这个计划的话就是暂停
比如说你推广的
这报品推广了
这个产品
非常非常多的点击
但是效果很差
已经超过了一两个月了
那么这种计划直接暂停就可以了
那么你创建新计划的时候
你在出价方面
在屏蔽识方面
马上直接用上它的屏蔽识
出价方面跟它不一样
可能你要出高一点
第二个就是你在
选择国家这里选择国家的时候
一定要马上就选择你
最精准的国家去推广
不精准的
全部不要了
这里分时段不用设置
把定向标签选择
跟你原来那个计划
可以是一样
但是呢
你把那些低质量的标签
在这个新计划里面就不要高溢价了
你要优先溢价那些
之前效果比较好的那些标签开始
这样的话你的整个新计划才更有效
那么这个就是关于我们
寻盘质量提升的一些方法
第一次听
可能你没有那么了解
那么你可以听多一到两遍
同时呢
听的过程中
你要去思考加后台操作
一边去看后台的摆块
一边去判断
再去调整
调整了之后
你要经过三到七天
去看数据
持续的看数据
持续的优化
再对比前后调整的效果怎么样
这样去做
那么你后续
你只要碰到同类问题
那么你都能够有一个非常清晰的思路
去解决这些问题
我们这节课就讲到这里
关键是大家一定要行动起来
我们下节课再见